hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i thought i'd do a video on the whole
area of
blind audio testing
control listen and test and listener
training critical listeners
there seems to be a lot of confusion not
just in one camp but
both camps if you will the truth is
closer to the objective side but
there's a lot involved in this that i'd
like to cover
but let me start uh telling you a story
as some of this objectives tend to do in
their videos
i arrived at microsoft back in 97
and the first group i managed was the
signal processing team it was a group of
about 20 phd researchers
and engineers that were building
audio compression products at the time
and i thought okay i'll you know
let me go look out there's mp3s what
everybody's using
and i thought i'd go ahead and encode
some file into mp3
and uh haven't been an audio file for 30
plus years i thought i'd be a walk in
the park
tell them the difference between the two
i gotta tell you
it was a shock the mp3 file was about
eight percent the size of the original
so
about 92 percent thrown away that's what
you get at 128 kilobits per second
yet there was hardly any difference
between the two
i was just shocked i thought hey i just
listened to it and instantly i can tell
you know eyes are gone or bass is gone
or
something's happened to it and it was
quite humbling experience
so now when i read somebody says oh i've
been an audiophile for
40 years i i know what i'm talking about
my ears tell me the truth
like no no no no being an audiophile
doesn't qualify you to hear what i call
small impairments small london
non-linearities
if i take a file and changes highs and
changes lows
we all hear that so that is not in
question the tonality we can all listen
to two speakers and say yeah they sound
different from each other
and but when you take a file and
either compress it lossy or
you get into areas of amplifier
distortion dac distortion
and cables we're talking about very
small
impairments or defects down to
potentially nothing
and that's a whole other domain
people are not born equally whereas we
are born very similar by the way when it
comes to linear
anomalies the highs and the lows and
everything we tend to like similar
things
despite what people think but back to
small impairments small artifacts which
i tend to cover in a lot of my
measurements we're not born equally
and that's what the story is about so i
was quite disappointed here i'm managing
this group that's supposed to
develop lossy compression and and i
can't tell
what's what and uh so i thought this is
not good uh i got
lucky in that at that time the focus was
on streaming uh
music and voice over dial-up modems
broadband was just getting started
and so we're interested in how good of a
sound you can get at
20 kilobits per second which is what you
got in a 28k vps uh
modem and uh i can i say i got lucky
because at 20 kilobits per second the
artifacts are quite clear
uh you're now down to less than half a
percent of the music is kept
we butcher both the spectrum and
fidelity to be able to get files to be
so
tiny and so that was good to hear
what the artifacts are when they're
magnified thousand times or
you know ten thousand times so that was
helpful second thing was helpful
was that i had a team that was building
this technology so i could have
uh whiteboard discussions with them
about what they were doing
and how the process worked i then
started the reading
educating myself i was fortunate that
part of my electrical engineering degree
i had taken signal processing classes
which at the time i didn't think were
going to be useful for anything
but uh i sort of had that background so
i could converse with my team and
understand their
terminology and what they were saying
and and
uh i used that knowledge then to try to
understand what the artifacts were um
for example in lossy compression
we use a window a chunk of music
and that chunk can clear artifacts where
the artifacts bleed before a transient
and that's called pre-echo so once you
understand that that
the compression works on a frame and a
frame at a time basis
and how uh what called quantization
noise can bleed into the whole frame
and then what a pre-echo is that was
helpful uh the third thing that was
helpful is what we call
codec killer tracks
international standards like mpeg and
others were involved in developing
lossy compression algorithms and as a
result
researchers engineers had found clips
that were a lot more critical
in showing artifacts you could find
thousands of clips where have been fully
transparent even with mp3 encoding
but there were clips that were the
opposite that was show pre-echo that had
the right conditions in them
despite all that it wasn't an overnight
process it took me i'd say about four to
six
months to go from gosh i can't even tell
what's what it's like if you're not an
ice cream taster and somebody put you at
the end of it
i screamed many fashion lines they tell
me if today's production is right
like it all tastes like ice cream to me
to
complete opposite where it became sort
of child's play for me able to
find these artifacts and uh it became
known as
you know golden ear people called them
which i didn't like the term because
i didn't think i had anything to do with
my ears being golden i
had simply trained myself and i knew
technically what the artifacts would be
and and then i had this tremendous
feedback loop in that when i found
something i could talk to my research
team and engineers and then say is this
the case and they would say
whoa well let me go look and come back
say yeah there was a bug there and
we fixed it now listen i'm like oh now
the artifact's gone
so i had this feedback loop and
examination if you will where
i would think i know something and i
would do the testing and then
objectively my team would be able to
confirm
whether i was imagining some flaw in in
the encoding
or there was a real problem and they
would fix the real problem so it was 100
proof something was wrong that i had
detected these things
so it became a great satisfaction to be
able to do this so even though my job
wasn't to
do the work of my team i would often be
their sort of their
checkpoint where they would come to me a
few months say i'm here we've got a
new encoder with a new psycho acoustics
model can you test it can you do some
critical testing
um that would put me through blind tests
i would put inside a test so
i was always happy to do that and i want
to enjoy finding these artifacts
and letting them know what the problems
were
so one of the interesting things that
came out of this training was that i
didn't just learn to hear
compression artifacts i learned how to
convert myself
from an enjoying listener an audio file
to
an analytical machine where i change
modes and i
paying attention to what music and this
beauty is indeed a lot of music that was
revealing wasn't beautiful
but i would learn that you know you
gotta
you know that laid back thing is not
enough that you gotta
focus and focus and understand and
look for things i would often create a
loop of half a mil
a half a second or quarter of a second
or just one note
one guitar ding ding ding and i would
just play it
and i would do an a b test and i said ah
look listen right here that the
thing was sounding different so you
develop some inherent capabilities that
you wouldn't normally have
as an audio file because i was becoming
a tester and
you know an analysis type of person i
guess the closest analogy is
uh when people lose their sight and they
rely on their hearing more and they're
able to
pick up things or people can read lips i
can't read lips but uh
clearly people can even understand you
know what you're saying by just watching
your lips
we don't you know we we probably watch
each other's lips to help with our
comprehension but not to that
level so training to become what i call
a critical listener
is super important and it is a hundred
percent valid valid
uh uh skill to have every top
um company to develop compression
algorithms
dolbies of the world apple and others um
actually apple wasn't one of those but
other companies have developed
compression they always had one or two
people like me or you know if they're
lucky more but
usually very few people that had just
invested in time and energy and
and had the inclination to become good
and they rely on
on them and and you know you go look at
research papers
you will routinely see that they say hey
we took a trained
group now the word training is misused
sometimes
sometimes that's assumed to be
experienced per listener
somebody mastering music is trained in
listening
for mastering to me that's not the same
as being a critical listener
that same listener despite having
training may have
no ability to be able to find small
impairments
so just because you're trained in in
something doesn't make you automatically
there
you need to go through a process of
understanding what artifacts they are
what the problems are
and then be able to uh use that now
everything i told you just now you
should assume it could be garbage
i could have made all that up i could
have exaggerated all of this
indeed i watch videos i read things from
companies that say well we've done a lot
of blind tests ah we can tell
it's easy i've had 10 years of training
listening to cables or listening to
these wires listen to this
and i can tell and you can't tell
because
you know you're a newbie you don't
haven't done that 10 years
so you should trust me and come buy this
cable
and i said whoa whoa whoa whoa that's
like taking an exam
and giving yourself an a and saying
look um you know i've got an a student
like no
somebody else needs to grade you in my
case i had my
phd researchers and developers actually
testing when i said hey this thing is
broken listen this
quarter second guitar string that's
wrong that would go and check and
sometimes they came back and said
nonsense amir take this blind test
and i tell you i would fail i would tell
them that there there is something
inside it and then i would not be able
to find it in blind it would be quite
embarrassing and i can tell stories of
that
so i had a feedback loop just like when
you go to school there's a teacher
exams your grade your grade your exams
you have to do that so this notion that
i've done this for 10 years therefore i
can tell
it's just totally nonsense there needs
to be some existence proof
so what existence proof is there for me
well when i've told these stories online
people have challenged me and they said
nonsense you know nobody can tell these
differences you're making all this stuff
up
mp3 is transparent so i don't know what
you're talking about so
in in the years of these battles going
on with objective as our own camp
um i've developed you know i've taken
tests that people
have thrown at me so let me show you
some of those tests
um these are tests that are public so
i'm showing you the origins of them you
can go maybe find this i don't know for
all cases the
content is still there i think most of
them are there one of them was uh
this nice objective is um um
uh online blogger called archimago
and uh he's a secret person doesn't tell
us who he is but
he writes very good articles and his
website's
you know popular so i encourage you to
go read his writings
he often puts out these blind tests um
and uh he put one out there called 24
bit
that was about 24 bit versus 16 bit
audio test
i did not see the test till the test was
over
so i did not participate in his test
but i remember it coming up somebody
saying you know here's a test could you
have passed it
and at the time the files were still
there and i went downloaded them
and uh but before i tell you how i did
this was the outcome he asked people an
incorrect
question by the way he asked them if
they can tell which one's a better
sounding one and of course people are
all confused or or the results were
basically the same just as many people
said the 16-bit sample was 24-bit that
they said
24-bit sample was the 24-bit so
he then concluded nobody can tell
difference between these
and partially is right so if the
fidelity of high-res music is
is so clear therefore you know it should
have been easy for people who are
advocates of 24-bit to be able to tell
the difference
but i say he's wrong enough before we
can say
something's better which is a preference
and we have no real
example there it's not like we had the
live music and then we had the 16 and
24-bit version of it to compare
just two files which one's better we can
just imagine one being better and vote
that way or imagine the other one being
better and voting that way and
that's just placebo bias and and just
preconceptions get in the way or
or luck and and what have you so i like
his tribe but
it wasn't the fair question the fair
question would have been
um well let me put this way he asked the
populist question which is that people
would just say i can easily tell the
difference he's proven
people can't easily tell the difference
but from my point of view a more
fundamental question is
would there have been any difference in
these two files now he was a
clever son of a gun he got help from a
signal processing expert to solve a
problem with his public test
which is what i call mechanical analysis
somebody can
take these two files and let's say it's
a
high bandwidth file versus low bandwidth
file and bring them to an audio analysis
program and instantly tell
one is higher bandwidth than the other
and therefore the gig is up and they
know the answer and they can
vote accordingly in this case the sample
rate was the same so that game couldn't
be played anyway but he also went
through some countermeasures with the
help of a signal processing person to
make it
very difficult to actually even analyze
the bits and be able to arrive at which
one's 24-bit which one 16-bit
so quite clever and i can tell you that
i did not do any mechanical analysis and
i would have been happy to have you sit
next to me or anybody sit next to me and
i would pass the test and i'm going to
tell you how i passed the test
anyway so hopefully you can go copy
what i've done so now this is the tracks
to use now
the de facto standard tool online and
unfortunately there's only one of them
there's a pro player called fubar 2000
it's a geeky player so i don't use it
for every day but it has
plug-ins and somebody wrote a plug-in to
do an avx test
abx test it presents you the two samples
a b
and the two that we want to know if
they're different from each other and
then randomly picks a
or b and calls them x and your job is to
tell whether x
matches a or matches b and you vote with
two buttons
and uh so whenever somebody's challenged
usually they demand
people demand to run this there
unfortunately doesn't run on a mac there
is a
mac abx program um not very popular but
that exists
um and there's some issues with this
plug-in i'll talk about later on but for
the purpose of this
testing is not so i gave it these two
files and then you run it and you know
you can listen to a as long as you want
you can listen to b as long as you want
and you can listen to x as long as you
want
you can immediately vote or you can take
five days to vote the program doesn't
care it just sits there waiting for you
and when you're done listening so
there's this notion of
there's time pressure there wasn't uh i
was sitting there by myself
on my house doing the listening test i
was using a laptop with uh
at emotive
iem so good iems in-ear monitors but
uh but nothing fancy laptop sound card
so
this didn't require you know very high
and dac and what have you
and as you can see the way the report
works is it gives you the time stamps so
you can see
that i started the test and it took me
two minutes and then
i was pretty quick so uh on this thing
but i could have taken
like that weeks and days i'll explain
later on when that's a bad idea but
but i did so i ran the test one out of
one i could tell
test uh one out of one i got it
and that means this 50 chance i guess
right i could have said x was a or b
and 50 percent chance i could get lucky
the second one i actually failed
so the program penalizes back it says no
no no
you know there's 75 percent as you could
guess because you got
two out of three wrong but then as you
can see i kept
up and i was able to guess correctly
every time
and you can see the time stands uh
pretty close so in eight or nine seconds
i could tell
and i kept taking it taken a decade and
at this point i stopped you can stop it
anywhere you want
and as you can see i got 14 out of 15
rights of one miss over here
and usually you know you can lose your
concentration there's a difficult task
so you gotta focus and
all of a sudden somebody talking a dog
barking or whatever um
you could get wrong and also one source
of getting things wrong is i i
get forgetful i push the wrong button
you know i know it's b but i
click a and boom i was like oh no and
there's no going back
you know short of taking the test again
but anyway um
as you can see i got 14 out of 15 trials
right so probability of guessing it says
0.30
but it's actually 0.0 some number um
it's a flip of a coin so 50 chance your
head's a tail
and how many heads in a row can you get
before somebody can believe you that you
can
always get ahead so it's a cooked coin
if you will
so by the time you get to 14 out of 15
you
you know i could still get lucky so this
could be luck
but uh the probability of that is
extremely low so i would not
bet against against this person not
knowing what they were hearing
um so how did i how did i pass this test
uh i could tell you that it's an
impossible test for you to pass if you
don't know what i'm about to tell you i
sat back and i
i first listened to just different parts
of the cliff eclipse
and it was hopeless they sounded the
same
then i sat back and i said well where
does it matter to have more bits
it matters when the amplitudes are
dropping so we've exhausted what 16 bits
could do and we drop into what 24 bits
could do
and that if i could find such a segment
and then i would turn up the volume
because when amplitude is dropping the
thing is getting very quiet i may not be
able to hear
what's down there there may be
differences but there's too quiet i
can't hear
by the way using in-ear monitors that
blocks outside noise
is extremely useful as is being able to
turn up the volume
so i went to the end of the track and
got lucky because there was a fade to
zero
and when one faded to zero one had
higher noise floor than the other
boom i knew what to listen for and
managed to pass the test so what allowed
me to pass it
technical knowledge i understood what
the difference between 24 bit 9
and 16 bit was that it's in the
quantization noise it's in the
low bits not in you know channel
separation
or you know transients or base impact
none of those
it was where i knew the amplitudes are
small and if you divide up a small
signal
you know into more parts than less parts
more parts always better
so when the guy says hey i'm making
these cables i don't know how to measure
anything
i don't really can't even explain to you
why it sounds better but i can hear it
it's like
well you can't do what i just did in
this test because you don't know what to
listen for
yeah you might think you do but you
don't because you have no foundation
to know if you have measurements and the
measurements told you hey
frequency response rolled off above 18
kilohertz okay you could devise a test
where you could tell
but if you don't understand the system
then you're screwed
and indeed i would have been screwed if
i didn't have this technical knowledge
and if you don't have the technical
knowledge that's why i say it would be
hopeless for you
and indeed was hopeless for all those
people who took this test they did not
know what to listen for
so did i cheat you could say i cheated
but the purpose of a system for
transmitting
music is that it's transparent what i
call for all people
all listeners and all situations and all
content
so to extend in a fade i could tell the
difference i could tell you 16 bit is
not transparent
done and today 24 bit costs nothing
all music is produced in 24 bit and then
dumb down to 16
i'm like give me the 24 bit i don't want
you dumb it down to 16 i'll
pay for the extra file the size and let
me listen to it and not ever have a
condition where that happens
now again if you threw me out in the
middle of those tracks
i could not tell and if it didn't give
me this tool where i could focus just on
the last
you know a few milliseconds of the track
and repeat it
i couldn't be able to tell it either you
know just walking in somebody says hey
can i tell the difference in this
my answer would be no i'll be just as
stupid and dumb as the next person i
shouldn't got stupid dumb
basically i wouldn't be able to perform
any miracles in here
now you might say well this is one test
maybe you got lucky this one you cheated
what have you
there's been a lot of these tests uh
published over time
ethan weiner is a hardcore objectivist
friend of mine
and does a lot to educate people about
you know what's voodoo and what's real
and sometimes he creates these tests
there is quite embarrassing for people
in that he exaggerates the effects that
people think
you know are terrible in themselves and
you exaggerate some heavily and says
well
can you tell the difference now and if
you can't tell difference when i
exaggerate something
tremendously then you're really it
really holds so this notion that the dax
sound different that
analog digital converters sound
different than the screw up music
he went ahead took a file and in this
case he had a good
uh interface to focus right and he
looped
he played a file music file on disk
played it and then captured it with the
same card
played it captured the play they
captured and played the capture and and
he did
different versions one which was one
generational loss one that was five and
one was ten
and one was twenty whatever well i tell
you that hardly any audiophile there
to take this test if you just casually
listen to it you will not be able to
pass it down
if you don't it's a tough tough test and
then this one i didn't take notes of
what i found in there but let me show
you how i did on on this test you can
see this starts with
you know the same as you know i think i
missed the first one actually
so it's telling me that i'm guessing
completely but as the test progressed
you can see that i finished down here
and i got 19 out of 22 right
with again you know zero percent so 19
tells you that
occasionally i did hiccup if you go look
in here you probably find that
uh usually yeah you can tell in here
where i was down to 1.1
chance of guessing and all of a sudden i
missed one and got to 2.9
so it took a lot of concentration
tremendous amount of my listening skills
were involved in
in trying to find this it wasn't such oh
you know i'm just gonna
whistle dixie and pass this this was not
easy this was a one generation one i
believe
which was the hardest ones the ones that
were 10 generations were a lot easier
for me to pass versus the one generation
sorry about the phone bp
um on this thing so
he then had another one with really
embarrassed people which was the sound
blaster which people you know it's an
older
you know pc card that you know any
high-end audio file would have a heart
attack if you told them how to listen
music through that
and uh said oh yeah this is the single
pass one which is the most difficult one
and again hardly anybody could take this
test and pass it and you can see that
that this one
i had no trouble and from what i recall
it was uh this one was actually slight
softening
of the high frequencies how did i know
that i thought about it i said well
every time you digitize this there's an
anti-aliasing filter
that filters out the highs and this has
been a cheaper card it doesn't have the
best anti-aliasing card
so i bet you there's some high frequency
loss in there
and i managed to find it now when i ran
this test i think
uh let's say the data 2014 so
six years so i was still in my 50s so my
high frequency was long gone yet i was
able to pass this and this is not
cheating this is literally me listening
and able to find that that's slightly
different so
um shows you that if you're a critical
listener you can get damn good at this
stuff so
don't go around waving your hands and
nobody can pass all these things it's
all nothing you know
quality doesn't matter everybody
everything's the same all digital's the
same
i'm showing you that you know there are
people like me that
do hear this stuff and therefore
striving for quality
is a good thing and by the way it costs
nothing to strive for quality
if you go to adios review website you'll
see that there's tons of tons of
dirt cheaps products that are superb way
beyond
anything in here these are real
degradations that we're talking about
they're
they're not esoteric things so on this
thing
so um the late arnie krueger
was probably the most staunch uh
objective is he was
involved in the original uh development
of the apx tests and he spent a lifetime
fighting subjectivism online and
and i actually had a lot of fights with
him because he would tell me that i i
can't pass these tests
so you know i i try to state the truth
and i would try to pull them from that
extreme position with you not just down
saying no
no no you can't just keep saying you
know a 10
dac must be perfect even though you
haven't
determined that it's perfectly measured
and what have you so
he had these tests he created back in
1980s
for jitter and he took he generated a
30 hertz jitter that means you take a
deck and you subject it to
30 hertz uh variation that creates two
side bands
around every tone that's only 30 hertz
apart the
perceptual masking is extremely
effective in covering that up
so indeed if if you see jitter and you
see spikes close to it i'll always tell
you it's inaudible because perceptual
masking
is because of that and so these tests
were not easy to tell
to hear nobody that i know took these
tests but me
and i went downloaded this file and as
you can see
10 out of 10 times i have to pass it uh
this is uh
also an opportunity to tell you about
the new version which now see it sort of
doesn't say zero percent here
some people start accusing me of
cheating they said you could uh
you could uh let me pause you i'll be
right back
hi there i'm back uh perils of doing
video during the day
when everybody's calling what have you
all right uh let's get back to this test
as i was uh explaining this is a jitter
test but an extremely difficult one to
pass
and because of the perceptual masking
that
our ear and brain apply so
he created three different ones i think
i passed two levels of it i could not
pass the third one
and this is the second from the worst
one and
as you see i managed to pass ten out of
ten very very very difficult to
test around but going back to why this
display looks different than the
previous abx test
is that people were accusing me and
others to go in there and just use a
text editor and make up these numbers
which you could
but obviously when somebody like me post
under my real name last thing i want to
do is
destroy my reputation and uh by faking
results so
i went ahead and used the new plugin
that has a cryptographic hash in there
basically it's a checksum
of the contents of the file so we know
the files haven't been messed with
and there's a signature cryptographic
signature that's generated for all of
this together
which means that if you edit this file
this outcome
the output you'll be able to use that
there's a tool that actually reads this
file and tells you if it's valid
and we can also apply you know find out
if the two original source files were
you know messed with and then renamed as
these two
um people still come back and say well
amir knows enough about this stuff that
he can bypass that uh give me a break
[Laughter]
it's not worth for me to even mess with
the original thing let alone this so
if you can't pass these things it's
understood it does require scale doesn't
mean i have better ears than you it just
means that you know i've done this work
professionally and even in difficult
situations i'm able to uh
dig in and find the differences and as i
mentioned that this top test was
extremely hard
to tell and i could not hear
by the way the the team that builds this
plug-in
continued to make it harder for people
to pass this test and what they
did was that uh i haven't run for a
while is that they
stopped telling you how you were doing
during the test i think that's totally
wrong
um we want to maximize the chances that
somebody can pass these tests
not minimize it it's not a game we're
playing somebody is able to look and
find out that they're on the right
segment in the track that's revealing
is hugely useful we don't want to put
our head in the sand saying oh
let me see how i can tie your hands
behind your back and then you see
how fast you can run it's like no i've
got a different parts of the file are
impacted
differently with jitter or different
artifacts and i listen to one section
and i take the test if i keep failing
then i stop and then i go and pass
another you know test another section
if you take away this tool from me it
will just take forever to do this
sorry i had to pause you again cogs were
uh
barking anyway i actually lied to you
this is the uh
um uh i think this is like the highest
one or next highest one but anyway
there's a
version of it that actually was even
more difficult to pass
and you can see here i started to
struggle some now
uh from uh standards in the industry
if your probability of guessing is less
than five percent
that's accepted to be good enough or we
usually write as p
less than 0.05 and you see that very
very commonly in research paper on
validity of
of listening tests and i'm at 5.5
so you know it passes that test
personally i'm not as happy with it i'd
like to show you tests where it's so
clear where this is zero as close as
zero as you can get that
that it should be no doubt that i could
pass that test
this one would be good enough for
research but
not rising to my standard uh on this
thing this was again a
very difficult test of jitter at 30
hertz although the amplitude is much
higher than
the typical amounts that that we see it
in in these tests
um now i've told you i've sort of in
some up to now we've been talking about
some of the assumptions we make on
objectivist side where such tests are
impossible to pass everything sounds
different that
people can't test blind tests and none
of these people claim to
hear stuff ever take a blind test well
i've taken these blind tests i've posted
them many times people have argued with
me to death on them and
and uh they're there so
there's existence proof of life here so
don't be too cocky and saying
you know nobody can pass anything you
know let me just throw an mp3 at you and
uh let's see if you can pass us indeed
people have done that and i've passed
those tests to their embarrassment
so don't go too far you know our
argument is good but not
bulletproof in some of these cases now
people say that the uh ah this has
no good i can't pass them because
there's a time pressure as i mentioned
there's no time pressure program has no
timer and that you could take forever
uh but they said no no no i really want
to listen these things these things uh
cable whatever take it home and listen
to my system my music and my whatever
well guess what that test has been done
formally and it's published in
aes paper for which i've done the digest
i'll put a link in the
description um it comes from this aes
paper audio engineering society
paper and summarizes 10 years of
abx testing and and what the results are
most of you don't have access to those
files so i've taken it and i've carved
out a key part of it which is
people argument that long-term testing
is better than short-term
testing as i mentioned i tell you it is
the absolute opposite of truth if you
told me to listen to all these files
that i showed you that i'm going to
listen to one
for days and then i'm going to listen to
the other track for days i couldn't pass
any of them i'll make it even simpler
if he told me that there's going to be
20 second laps between when i listen to
a
and then listen to b again i would flunk
most if not
all of these tests the reason i'm able
to find these differences
is that i shortened the clip to very
small increments and i've looped it
so when i'm switching a and b we have
what is called echoic memory
which is almost a lossless recording in
our brain
where everything that comes in we record
and then
after a while we say wow that's a huge
amount of data
um we need to commit something to
long-term memory and what we commit to
long-term memory is the most massive
lossy
encoder you could think of it's like
thousands of times
you know compressed you will hear you
will remember it was a female singer and
maybe some guitar playing but you're not
going to know remember all the nuance of
everything you hear in
life or you would go crazy so
we want to take advantage of the echoic
memory because in short-term memory
because
it is far far more accurate so you want
to have this
a and a b in mind just
within that you know a few seconds
people say correct memory can last up to
20
20 seconds i can tell you even though
like two or three seconds is enough for
me to fail a lot of these tests
uh harman does speaker testing despite
the large difference in speakers
there's like four or five second delay
because they've got to shuffle
speakers i tell you i'm dying there
while i'm waiting for the next speaker
to play i'm trying to say
remember remember remember remember the
last speaking last speaker
thankfully the differences are massive
they're between speakers so you sort of
remember
but i tell you it's crazy for people to
say long term listening is better
but it's been tested so um
clark was one of the advocate and
builders of original abx test
part of this detroit listening group
and they had another audiophile group
that was all these golden ear high-end
ones and they had a competition
and to see if in a blind test people
could tell the difference
um with a box that instead added two and
a half percent distortion so
a lot of distortion the high-end audio
files immediately said no no
no no no i'm not gonna even listen to
the setup you have in here it's beneath
me
i'm only gonna listen to this at home
i'm gonna do my own long-term testing
i'm not gonna sit down to this abx game
you're playing with your relays they're
probably screwing up the sound mode and
you know what you're doing i'm not gonna
do it so
they changed the test and they built
these uh black boxes
ten of them they built they were battery
powered and uh
half of them had uh um
distortion that they added two and a
half percent half of them
had passed through so it didn't do
anything and they
randomly gave this to both teams uh of
these audiophiles
well both of them came back afterwards
failed could not identify either the
pass-through one or not so this
long-term listening take home
and listen on your own system your own
content everybody failed
this test so you know people who think
they could do better by take home
they're
totally wrong as long as the s is blind
right here they couldn't tell what the
boxes were doing
and then but then they did a second test
where they use the avx compatible
comparator
which just like the fubar tool lets you
quickly listen to a b a b
a b and n x boom not only these guys
they were able to hear um
uh the uh you know 11 out of 18 people
could hear this difference
they also went on later on actually
reduced the distortion
and they still were able to detect that
uh using abx testing that's
fast instantaneous testing so there's no
question
whatsoever both in research and i'm
telling you from my years and years or
years of experience
that if you lengthen that time
your your toast the kind of small
distortions that we're talking about and
these are real distortion two and a half
percent distortion
show me a power cable that has two and a
half percent distortion added to your
audio system it does not exist we can't
even measure what it adds
to the system level on two and a half
percent and uh
anytime i'm challenged to do a b testing
like hdmi
testing is a nightmare because hdmi
takes forever to relock and
show another source of two sources in
hdmi and i've tried
by time to think glitches switching from
channel you know from a input to b input
i'm gone i mean i can't hear the
difference between these things so
it's just an excuse people have saying
long-term testing works better
why do they arrive at that because they
go home and they plug in this cable at
first they think it didn't sound good or
it did sound good and
two months later they decided on some
other outcome they say aha
it took me two months to figure out what
this cable was doing my system
my answer is no you have no idea what it
did to your system because
it wasn't the control test and you
graded yourself you said the highs got
better the veil was removed who says the
veil was removed in the black you could
say anything
maybe nothing was removed and by the way
that's the heart of all these systems
we're taking human beings they're
totally
unreliable instruments compared to my
analyzer
a human being even i am a terrible
instrument
when you're using me to test audio
electronics
i'm going to feed you variable data
right it's a subjective test control but
it's subjective test
so we want to find out within the noise
of the experimentation
what is real and what is not so
oftentimes we put controls in the test
where we put putting something that
sounds a lot worse like this two and a
half percent box
and then we can tell people can't tell
the difference then they
totally host because they couldn't even
hear the control where we know the
answer we know it added two and a half
percent
distortion if you can't tell that's the
end of the discussion but that's because
we have the answer
we know there's a box with 200
distortion you buying a high-end cable
taken at home and plugging it in
and arriving at some conclusion we don't
know
we have no way of verifying that we
don't have the cable we haven't measured
it we don't know what you
so what you're claiming you you heard is
of zero value
what is of value is that we test you
enough times
and then we perform a statistical
analysis that says aha
there's one percent chance you you know
you were guessing or there was 100
chance you were guessing
lay people by the way they think oh i
did a blind test and
i did it once and i could tell different
so i did it twice i could tell the
difference like no
twice is not good enough that's why i
said you gotta do 10 out of 10 times
you can't just you know declare yourself
as as you know
being right and unfortunately
audiophiles always do this they keep
saying they're right because they've
been an audiophile
for so many years no these are
differences that are supposed to be
actually impossible to hear
so and you're claiming but ease you take
these cables in here
by the way the expectation that the
cable wasn't supposed to sound good or
whatever the tweak is for that matter
not just cable
that i didn't expect it to sound good
but it did oh i expected to not like it
now like
none of that matters that's all wording
your frame of mind
is just of no value to us we just want
to know
if we can test you 10 times so if you
think this coaster under your
amplifier made it sound better let's
make two coasters that look the same one
has the bits in it that you think makes
sound good one that doesn't
and then we have you do a blind test and
do it 10 times
so you know if it was night and day the
veil was removed great you wouldn't take
six months to do this take six months to
do it
so uh let me summarize them let's get a
long video
um that there's such a thing as as
training with training you can get
better
if the differences are real the training
requires rigor requires
knowledge of the system which is very
complicated
um it is not joe below saying i've been
making cables for 10 years and i know
what to listen for i know how to
you know i've got this rack for audio
and you put stuff in there
and i did it blind with somebody and
they said it was fantastic now what
he or she said we can't trust we've got
to have
a structure and a rigor you know people
have that when they develop medicine
same here we don't just wave our hands
and invent our own protocols
uh don't use the word blind you know
just willy-nilly
uh you know blind means being able to
demonstrate the protocol first thing
people ask
what what does it mean what did you do
uh on this thing did you match levels
you know what was the condition what
should how did you test and those
details are
seemingly never come so um
but also don't go the other extreme of
assuming that nobody can pass any of
these tests the small differences are
no you know i mean nothing i've had
people say
192k is good enough and nobody can tell
well
you know i can tell in in these tests so
i'll have more to cover on on this topic
but i was watching uh
the uh founder of jps
that makes his iron cables uh keep
mentioning that he's done blind tests
and that he's uh
um you know he's done bail cables for 10
years and he's
trained himself to to uh know what gable
sound like the different material sound
like what
yet he doesn't know how to measure him
he doesn't know how to correlate any
measurements with anything and there was
nobody there to grade him so he just
decided that he
knew and knows now what different cables
sound like
one we can prove that those cables don't
have a sound
and the fact that he thinks he knows is
not sufficient we need to test them
and of course he says blind tests uh i
don't know what he says about blind test
i've watched a video of him for half an
hour i could
make heads and tails out of his position
of what he thinks
on this thing but know that there's good
signs in here
blind tests and training and so forth is
part parcel
of research go through the engineering
society and there's tons of tons of
papers there
that talk about these things okay
hopefully you found this useful i'm
sorry it doesn't have as many
graphs and measurements and things uh i
think listening tasks are critical
uh you know we listen i listen
two-thirds of my reviews have
listening tests in them a lot of people
keep asking why are you just reading
graphs i'm like no i'm listening you
know you're
the one that doesn't listen i've
listened to 140 speakers last year alone
how many speakers you've listened to and
compared in a controlled environment
on this thing so hopefully you got
something out of this rant and
video uh comment below and tell me if
you find it
useful and uh or not
okay see you in future videos bye bye